imagine earth with an even 50 50 split
between continents and oceans
our planet covered half by land and half
by water
how would this change the planet as you
know it
what new kinds of vacations could this
make possible for you
and what does the color of your pee have
to do with this
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the earth was half land and
half water
when it comes to making life possible on
a planet water is an absolute have
that's why we look for alien life on
worlds where liquid water could exist
when it comes to our own planet 71 of
its surface is covered by water
most of that is in our five oceans
together they form one global ocean
now if you replaced nearly a quarter of
our ocean water with land
how soon would earth turn into just
another lifeless rock in space
thanks to global warming earth's sea
levels are currently rising but if you
wanted to balance the planet's land to
water ratio
you'd see the sea levels absolutely
plummet
and not just a few meters but around
three kilometers
earth would look very different
the regions around both the north and
south poles would be completely dried
out and every continent on the planet
would expand
and not just a little either all this
newly emerged territory around the world
would be roughly equal to the current
surface areas of asia europe africa and
north america combined
that would be an enormous amount of
unused space
everything extending off the old coasts
would be relatively flat but some of the
areas that used to be deep ocean would
reveal vast corridors and steep
crevasses
as you explored this new land you'd
discover that the one global ocean
would be no more
all of the oceans would be separated
from each other and all of the
continents would be one connected
landmass
and this would be good news for
evolution
early humans didn't have any ships or
planes
we spread across the globe simply by
walking
venturing away from africa some seventy
thousand to one hundred thousand years
ago
we found our way to europe and asia
eventually we were able to cross a land
bridge connecting asia to the americas
possibly as far back as 20 000 years ago
with the 50 50 split in place you'd now
be able to cover even more ground
finally you could take that around the
world trip you've always dreamed of
all on your own two feet
but this shifting balance of water and
land wouldn't be all fun and games
with so much less water covering the
surface
our ocean currents would be disrupted
and this would seriously destabilize the
climate
currents distribute the heat that's
absorbed by the oceans around the globe
disrupting them would mean even colder
temperatures around the north and south
poles while the already hot equatorial
regions would get even hotter
climate change would speed up too
all because oceans wouldn't be able to
absorb so much carbon dioxide from the
air
that excess carbon dioxide would blanket
the planet and raise temperatures
rain levels would also drop off and this
would create dangerous droughts as well
as new deserts in many inland areas
so while there may be an abundance of
new land available
large stretches of earth could become
uninhabitable
plants animals and humans would all need
to adapt to being less dependent on
water
or at least start using it more
efficiently
water scarcity could result in animals
evolving to be smaller with more making
the jump to a strictly carnivorous diet
and sadly the abundance of life that
today's oceans support would struggle to
survive
and maybe the most surprising
consequence that you'd need to get used
to is that your pee would likely change
forever
usually urine is made up of more than 90
water
but with less water in your daily life
yours would become much darker and
start to smell like ammonia
i mean things could be worse
you could drain the oceans of every drop
of water they have
but
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]